معنا من عمان لواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك يعني
اخبار المعارك على الارض في تلك الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الى اين استراتيجيه
جديده يتبعها الطرفان الان
في ظل الجمود
بصوره عامه في المعارك الارضيه نحن نتحدث
عن خط يزيد عن 900 كيلو متر
المناطق النشطه والتي يجري بها معارك
ومحدوده
وخاركيف في باك موت هجمات اوكرانيه في
منطقه ليمان ايزيوم هناك
هجومات روسيه بدا الحديث في هذا اليوم عن
هجمات اوكرانيه
كنظره تحليليه سريعه كان اوكرانيا تسعى
الى تحقيق ما يطلق عليه المعركه التصادميه
لماذا لانها تعتبر بعد سنوات من تدريب
الغرب لها تتفوق في الاطار الكفاءه
الفرديه
وتتميز في بعد الاليات المقاتل المدرعه
فبالتالي تعتقد انها ستكسب المعارك
التصادميه لان بقيه خط وقف الخط التماس
محصن بخطوط دفاعيه لم يستطع الهجوم
التصادميه يعني ما هي ملامح تلك المعارك
التصادميه
الملامح هناك هجمات روسيه منذ اسابيع في
منطقه الشمال
تسعى للوصول الى نهر اسكل لانه اذا تحقق
لها ذلك ستتحرك باتجاه سلافيانسك
اكراماتوريسك افضل وسيله للدفاع هي الهجوم
فهل اوكران بداوا في هذا اليوم يتحدثوا عن
هجمات باتجاه الايمان هناك هجوم قادم من
الشرق الان نتحدث عن هجوم ليس مضاد انما
هجوم باتجاه الهجوم كما يقال
اي بمعنى اخر معركه تصادميه بين وحدات
مدرعه من كلا الجانبين يعتقد الجانب
الاوكراني انه صاحب اليد العليا بسبب
اعتماده العقيده القتالي الغربيه والاليات
دبابات وما شابه وعربات برادلي يعتبر انها
تتفوق وسي ربح في هذه المعركه هكذا اقرا
المعركه اما السؤال الشق الاخر الطائرات
المسيره هناك مسارين للحرب المسار الاول
مسار الجمود في نعم نعم بشكل الجنود في
المعارك الارضيه
وبالتالي تعويض عن هذا الجمود والاخفاق في
تحقيق نجاح كبير بالهجوم المضاد وتوقف
اتفاقيه الحبوب بدات اوكرانيا تنتقي
اهدافا في موسكو في معظم بيلوجرود في
الكورسك وتحديدا في شبه جزيره القرم
والبحر الاسود لتعوض الاخفاقات في المعارك
يعني بالاضافه الى هذه الهجمات بالمسيارات
هناك ايضا نشاطا يجري بوضوح في البحر
الاسود هناك عمليه انزال روسيه اليوم في
البحر الاسود الى اين يمكن ان يكون البحر
الاسود هو منطقه او مسرح جديد لتبادل
الرسائل بين الطرفين
هو بدا واصبح حقيقه منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
منطقه تبادل رسائل منذ الهجوم على جسر
كيرش ومن ثم الهجوم على احد الموانئ
اعطاب او الحاق ضرر
بسفينه انزال اصابه مدمره
الوعيد من الجانب الاوكراني
بحصر السفن الروسيه في الموانئ الروسيه
الحديث عن احتمال مهاجمه سته موانئ روسيه
مقابل خمسه اوكرانيه هو اصبح منطقه صراع
لكن اليد العليا فيه للجانب الروسي لان
امكاناته اكبر قدراته البحريه اكبر
القدرات الاوكرانيه محدده
بالزوارق الحربيه الموجهه او باستخدام
الالغام وهذا عليه اشاره حمراء او
باستخدام الصواريخ متوسطه المدى شكرا لك
لواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان